el salón aeronáutico normalmente tiene
en el centro el combate entre el europeo
ervuz y el americano Boeing este año
viene bajo el signo de la
descarbonización así lo ha querido el
gobierno francés y el propio presidente
Emmanuel macron que hace tres días
anunciaba que este país construirá una
industria de biocarburante de aquí al
año 2027 los pirineos atlánticos por
allí parece pasar por los biocarburantes
esa mezcla de restos orgánicos y aceites
usados la solución mágica del transporte
aéreo para dejar de ser uno de los
grandes emisores de CO2 de nuestro
planeta una fábrica en ese sentido es
una buena noticia ya que los
biocarburantes son muy raros y son muy
caros siete veces más que el kerosene
que se usa actualmente sin embargo esta
impronta que ha dado el presidente
parece contradictoria con la actitud de
los usuarios este verano en Europa vamos
a batir nuevamente un récord de
pasajeros en las líneas aéreas y también
un récord aquí en este salón del Rey se
anuncian más de dos mil encargos de
aviones que vienen sobre todo de India
de Arabia Saudita y también de Turquía
turquis Airlines ha adelantado Que hará
una compra históricamente grande para
esta compañía turca sino en lo que
respecta a los aviones al parque este va
a duplicarse los próximos 20 años va a
pasar de veinticinco mil a cuarenta y
siete mil la buena noticia Es que la
asociación internacional de tráfico
aéreo que representa un 83% del tráfico
se ha comprometido a alcanzar la
neutralidad carbono de aquí al año 2050